just last week this
was a sports hall now it's a testing
center for students heading home for the
holidays
from the university of east london
not a pleasant process but reassuring
when you're worried about bringing the
virus back
to your older relatives it's definitely
something that has been on my mind since
people have been talking about going
home for christmas and it's just it's
made me
much more relaxed as well as my family
back at home if you
are tested and you come back negative
you're able to just mingle with your
family without having that
extra worry it allows us to feel secure
confident
and to be in the same household just
before christmas
the government has sent thousands of
lateral flow tests to universities
across the country
the little kits return results in 30
minutes and
unlike other kinds of tests they can be
processed on the spot
although they're not as accurate
all the students we've spoken to today
say they're so glad this facility exists
because it means they can go home for
christmas and relax
with their families but just because you
taste negative today
doesn't mean you'll test negative
tomorrow
is there a risk that they relax too much
based on something which
isn't 100 percent the academic running
the center
says any test is better than none the
biggest concern that's been raised with
this lateral flow testing
is sensitivity and is not as sensitive
as the pcr test so i think for the
purposes that we're using this test
to get that snapshot of the status of
a person at that point in time
pre-travel
i think it's fit for purpose let's hope
that's right
because a lot is riding on these tests
the government just announced that
they'll be used over christmas
to let care home residents see and even
hug their families it's great to see
this new guidance that's just coming out
it it
offers a ray of light i think to
hundreds of thousands of families
and older people right across the uk
that at last after a long period of
being
able to be kept apart they're going to
be able to see each other again
to support its mass testing program the
government has cited the example of
liverpool
saying testing there brought about a
remarkable decline in cases
the data suggests a different conclusion
coronavirus cases in liverpool city were
already falling when mass testing was
introduced
and they fell in other nearby areas even
though none of these boroughs
had mass testing the scale and speed of
the mass testing effort
is remarkable but the government is
taking a big bet on it
when it can't be sure of the results
roland manthal sky news